Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and Arrow is
back, there was a lot of stuff from the Premiere
to talk about so this will be a top 10 and
my review.
But I’ll circle back around and try to hit
everything that happened.
And don’t worry I’ll also be doing a q&a
for both the flash and arrow tomorrow.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet.
I’ll wait just a sec...Okay, here we go.
Top 10 Moments
Number 10 - Team Arrow has been kicking ass
and taking names
Ever since the season 2 finale Oliver and
Team Arrow have been systematically taking
down organized crime.
The opening action scene is just an example
of how they’ve basically been steamrolling
every bad guy they can find.
And we get to see Roy roll into action in
his shiny new costume
Number 9 - Roy Harper is full on Arsenal
Stephen Amell joked at comic con that he now
had the second best suit on the show.
Roy’s does look pretty badass.
This is what it looks like when it’s not
super dark out.
It’s funny that it’s super cool but you
can’t really see a lot of the details, because
they always shoot it at night.
And for those asking, yes Roy is going to
be the Arsenal version of his character.
Not Red Arrow.
Number 8 - The Hong Kong Flashbacks
Amanda Waller is trying to get Oliver to work
for her as if he were a Suicide Squad member.
They haven’t used that term to describe
what he’s doing, but you can think of it
as a precursor to the Suicide Squad.
Oliver’s Handlers are Tatsu and Maseo.
In the comics, Tatsu, the wife, becomes Katana.
I’ve already done a big video explaining
her character that I’ll link in the description.
She’s probably going to be one of the flashback
characters that shows up in the future.
The actress that plays her Rila Fukushima
played Yukio in The Wolverine.
Number 7 - Quentin Unofficially joins Team
Arrow
He’s Captain Lance now and it looks like
he’s been helping oliver hunt down criminals
in the field for a while.
Obviously this episode brought some of those
extracurricular activities into question,
he’s back in the hospital.
But his speech with Laurel at the end was
basically him saying, my choice.
I’m not stopping.
Just like Diggle.
He’ll be working more directly with Oliver
this year and for some reason he’ll be bald.
I think that’s just because he has to wear
the captain’s hat and they thought it looked
silly with his hair.
Number 6 - Meet the New Vertigo
Peter Stormare makes for great villains.
He’s playing a villain on the Blacklist
right now which I think is a funny coincidence.
If you’re confused, he’s just taking up
the mantle
of Vertigo even though the Count died.
That was what his “Something’s never die”
speech was about.
He’s just going to be one of the mid-level
villains this year like Brother Blood was
last year.
The drug just brings out you’re biggest
fears.
I thought it was a bit silly to have Oliver
take another shot in the chest the second
time they fought.
I feel like he would have worn thicker body
armor after the first encounter.
Number 5 - Felicity Works in a Buy More
Neither she or Oliver work at Queen Consolidated
right now.
So Felicity is working tech support to earn
money.
The Brandon Routh intro was just a wink to
him being on Chuck.
He actually played a villain on that show,
I think it’s all on Netflix if any of you
haven’t seen it.
Since Brandon Routh is buying half of Oliver’s
company, they all might be working there again
really soon.
Most of his scenes will be with Felicity for
the first half of the season.
Number 4 - Ray Palmer Has A Plan to Save the
City
As you can tell, he’s supposed to be the
Atom from the comic books before he became
the Atom.
Yes, he will get a suit and he will fight
the villains with Team Arrow.
Brandon Routh said a month ago he’d seen
concept art for the suit and at the time they’d
only shot about 6 episodes.
So I’m thinking we’ll see the Atom Suit
in the mid-season finale.
The Arrow half of that episode, it’s a two
parter.
Is Called The Brave and The Bold.
So they’re basically doing Justice League
on TV.
Everyone can flip out about how cool that
is.
The other big half of his speech is about
re-branding Starling City as Star City.
That’s what it’s called in the comics.
The name starling is just something they changed
for the show.
I’m kind of wondering if they planned things
this way all along.
Like showing how Starling became Star City.
Just to address the 400 pound gorilla in the
room.
Yes, Ray Palmer will come between Oliver and
Felicity.
But I think when you guys see their scenes,
you’ll enjoy it.
Felicity is just going to have a few more
options available to her.
We even saw her kissing grant gustin in a
Flash Promo.
She’s got superhero’s beating down her
door to go on dates now.
Number 3 - Diggle and Lyla have a baby
I did not expect this to go down in the first
episode.
They’ll get some of their own Suicide Squad
episodes this season.
As for the baby, I don’t know what their
plan is to incorporate it into the story.
It’s a huge deal, but because filming with
babies is very difficult, they probably just
won’t show it a lot.
Number 2 - Sara is Killed
The person that shot her is Komodo, one of
the other mid-level villains.
For all intents and purposes she’s dead.
Or at least they want us to think that.
With the black canary mask rolling of onto
the ground.
It’s a giant call to action for Laurel this
season.
If you haven’t seen the pictures, Kate Cassidy
has been posting pictures of her workouts.
She’s pretty hardcore.
She’s giving stephen amell a run for his
money.
If you remember the boxing scene.
One of the fighters was JR Ramirez, he’s
playing Wildcat.
He’ll be getting some scenes with Laurel
soon.
So it’s possible he could train her to fight.
I’m not expecting Laurel Black Canary this
season, but it seems like they’re definitely
implying it’s going to happen soon.
and my Number 1 moment - All of the Olicity
This was like everyone’s fan fiction made
reality, but they take it all back at the
end of the episode.
They’re not going to keep on dating.
Felicity pretty much said that they were done
as a couple.
It sucks, but that doesn’t mean they’ll
never end up together.
Like I said though, she’s got a ship with
Grant Gustin and Brandon Routh.
So Felicity will be getting a lot of attention.
Oliver on the other hand will probably be
spending a lot of time brooding.
It seemed like he was completely turned off
from the idea of relationships.
So I don’t think we’ll be seeing a lot
of hookups from him.
There are a couple big things we did not see
in this episode.
Ra’s Al Ghul, Komodo, or at least his face,
and Team Merlyn.
The next episode is called Sara, so it will
directly follow up on that last scene.
Let me know though, what was your favorite
moment and what do you think of Brandon Routh
so far?
Most of
the people we missed will show up by the fourth
episode, Including Ra’s Al Ghul.
So Arrow
just like The Flash, is wasting no time in
getting things going.
Overall I gave The Episode a solid B plus.
It’s my new favorite Arrow premiere.